[Music]
so you're in need of some serious cash
but you've run out ways to make money
legally because the working man is a
sucker so it looks like we're gonna have
to explore more
creative means of making money 22
million dollars in
what are your options drug dealing is
for degenerate online fraud is too
boring but what if we robbed a jewelry
store
[Music]
now hear me out there are hundreds of
thousands of jewelry stores all over the
country filled to the brim with diamonds
and gold just waiting to be liberated
from their owner's hands compared to
other heists like robbing banks stealing
from jewelry stores isn't just classier
it could be worth a lot more money think
about it sure cash is king but how much
money can you really get away with one
bill weighs one gram four million
dollars will weigh about 40 kilograms so
how many 40 kilogram bass can you really
carry at once
[Music]
so if you want more than four million
dollars from one job which you should
you're going to have to introduce more
people into the mix which is more mouse
defeat and more mouse that can stitch
it's just a mess
but if you robbed a jewelry store one
single little stone could be worth a
hundred thousand dollars you can steal
the same 40 kilograms worth of cash in a
little handheld baggy filled with just
40 tiny diamonds that is the power of
robbing a jewelry store you can get away
with a lot more in a substantially
smaller package and don't feel bad for
the store owners you're not really
stealing from them they have insurance
insurance is going to cover them so
you're really stealing from the scummy
insurance companies anyways if you plan
your heist well enough it won't just be
a victimless crime then jewelry shop
owners will thank you after all you just
sold out their entire store so obviously
becoming a career drilled thief is the
only logical choice but there is a lot
more that meets the eye when it comes to
a successful jewel heist so let's learn
how to rob a jewelry store the right way
theoretically of course
seriously not gonna donate any illegal
activity here don't be a scumbag there
are plenty of ways to make a ton of
money legally your skill set
[Music]
very unique
[Music]
sure robbing a jewelry store could make
you a lot of money but getting rich and
staying rich is also about saving money
and one of the easiest areas to save
money in is cancelling subscriptions
that you no longer need the problem is
in today's world if you're like me you
literally have too many subscriptions to
keep track of that's where true build
comes in a great all-in-one personal
finance app that helps you stay on top
of your finances that i personally use
myself with truebill you can link up
your bank account it will analyze and
list out all the subscriptions you have
and how much they're costing you and
what's great is that you can cancel the
ones you no longer need within trubil
without ever leaving the app thanks to
their concierge service saving you a ton
of time and money this is by far my
favorite feature of true build and i
still use it to this day because again i
just have too many subscriptions to keep
track of another incredible feature of
true bill is that they would negotiate
to lower your bills on your behalf
here's how it works you select the bill
you want to lower maybe it's your
internet bill so you select your
internet provider then you enter in some
information about yourself like the
address where you're getting your
internet at so truebill can negotiate on
your behalf truebill has a 85 success
rate in lowering bills so if they're
successful you get to choose how much of
those savings you paid to truebill for
the service i usually choose 50 of
whatever they save me and that's
literally it they take it from there and
that's not all true bill is loaded with
other features that allow you to monitor
your credit score monitor your spending
track your net worth you can even set up
an automatic savings fund that you're
able to withdraw from at any time just a
ton of really useful features that i'm
proud to promote truebill has over 2
million members and they save their
members over a hundred million dollars
and counting all you have to do to start
using these features yourself is to
pause the video and go to truebuild.com
jig with the link below that's
truebuild.com with the link below so
they know i sent you thanks to true bill
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
before you even start planning your
heist you need to become an expert at
your product unlike money in a bank not
every diamond or piece of jewelry is
created equal and bigger doesn't mean
it's always worth more one of the best
jewel thiefs in america larry lawton
went to an actual gemological training
program at the gemological institute of
america to learn everything he could
about gems and jewels before he went
into business so just like any other
business or startup you need to educate
yourself all the great jewel thiefs in
the world can spot the difference
between a natural diamond a lab-grown
diamond and of course a fake diamond in
seconds
learn how to judge a gem's worth by its
size color cut and clarity and most
importantly no matter how much you're
able to steal it's all worthless unless
you can quickly sell it afterwards so
know exactly what can quickly sell on
the street a pearl necklace is going to
take way more time to offload than a
gold chain or a diamond ring that can be
broken down and sold in pieces once you
know what to look for and what's in high
demand on the streets it's time to
assemble your crew
[Music]
where did you guys get a group rate or
something
[Music]
every great jewel high starts with a
badass crew right well not so fast
having people to help you has his pros
like dealing with crowd control
instilling more fear into employees
cracking safes and filling up more bags
with jewelry but it also has some major
cons if the legal business world is
filled with cheating partners the
criminal underworld is a cesspool of
snitches scammers and backstabbers
people you can't see or call the cops on
so you need people you can trust to do
this a lot of pros keep it in the family
sure your siblings may turn on you but
is not as likely as some guy you met on
the dark web and if family is not an
option either work or loan or get the
upper hand after a robbery a crew member
may snitch if the reward for talking is
worth more than their cut of the heist
to solve this blackmail is your friend
money the cut you give someone for a
heist will only motivate people so much
but have some dirt on them and they'll
stay silent forever so gather a small
crew people you can manipulate or people
you can trust with your life
and remember if you mess up this step
you're as good as dead
[Music]
picking the right jewelry store is a
little bit more than just checking which
has the most expensive jewelry on
display ideally you want a rich area
where people don't own guns because you
know as a criminal you would rather rob
people who don't have guns so pick an
area like london and definitely avoid
places like texas scottsdale or miami
where you have no idea who's armed then
you want to look for the actual store
the best way to go about this is to look
at as many stores as possible and work
backwards you're going to want to choose
one that's easy to get out of what
doesn't matter if you steal millions and
jewels but your getaway is weak even if
it means casing 100 stores look for
shops that offer a clean easy getaway
once you've narrowed it down you also
need to look for shops that wholesale
jewelry meaning that they buy a bunch of
jewelry in bulk who then sell it to
customers that is where the real money
is you don't need to worry about what's
on display if you know they've got a
safe field loose gem somewhere in the
back that is the good stuff they're
often worth more and easier to sell once
you narrow it down to a few shops that
wholesale and have a clean getaway the
next step is to choose the one that's
easiest to case
[Music]
this step makes or breaks your heist you
need to learn everything about the store
how many employees does it have how many
security guards are people armed inside
who busses you in do employees have
panic buttons on them where do the
employees park their cars what's the
camera situation like when is it most
busy there where do people keep the
loose diamonds and lastly what is the
police response time once the alarm goes
off one of the easiest ways to go about
this is to go in as a potential customer
say you're looking for a gift for your
mom or wife take a look at the shop's
interior where are the cameras where is
the buzzer to open the door what is the
jewelry in the display case is worth
once you've got a lay of the land it's
time to look for the box tell the
salesperson you're looking for a custom
made piece you're going for a diamond
around 1.5 carats in most cases they'll
get out a box filled with neatly stacked
envelopes inside these envelopes are
separate loose diamonds take a look at
what stones they offer then ask for
something just a little smaller or
bigger you get an idea of how many loose
diamonds of what sizes they have in
stock now it should be easy to calculate
what sort of money you can make when the
employee puts the box away watch
carefully where it goes usually the most
expensive diamonds are kept in a
separate safe under a floorboard or in a
desk drawer that is the one you want the
main obvious vault is just a decoy
casing a shop can take weeks you have to
make several visits to the store and
maybe even buy something to build up the
right kind of trust maybe you asked to
use the bathroom to check out the staff
area and security desk on the way you
need to know everything about the store
from where the employees park to what
time they all come in
then comes the last step calculating
police response time the best way to do
this is to get someone to throw a brick
through a window or start a small fire
once the alarm goes off you can time
exactly how long it takes cops to get to
the scene this is how much time you'll
have once one of the employees or guards
eventually triggers the alarm once you
have all this info you're ready to go
[Music]
start your robbery with a misdirection
throw a molotov cocktail at a shopping
center across town and the police will
start heading in that direction away
from you if you're going during the day
wear hats masks and sunglasses to cover
your eyes thanks to kovin this step is
incredibly easy no one would look twice
as someone wearing shades and a mask
outside once you're buzzed in stay calm
you need to control the situation at all
times make sure none of the employees
have their hands under desks or in their
pockets that's where the panic buttons
are most robberies don't need violence
they just need intimidation the threats
of violence
go in guns blazing but remind people
that if they cooperate they'll get to go
home empty everyone's pockets and tie
their hands up with zip ties remind them
that being a hero is a death sentence
corroboration means a cool story to tell
their kids and that they're not getting
robbed the insurance company is getting
robbed then go for the box of loose
diamonds first if you have a safe
cracker let them get started if you're
taking the entire safe with you even
better and then lastly go for the
display cases at least one employee will
have the keys and you can spend the next
10 minutes filling up on jewelry and
gold
some of the best robberies can take up
to 15 minutes sometimes even half an
hour the key is to work methodically
stick to your plan keep a cool head and
don't panic you need to exude authority
over the people in the shop if you panic
your weakness will give some idiot the
courage to fight back
once you've got what you came for make
your getaway get as far away from the
jewelry store as possible without
drawing attention that means driving the
speed limit stopping at traffic lights
you don't want to get pulled over for
speeding only to be arrested for jewelry
theft once you get to a safe house away
from the streets parking lots or malls
that have cameras it's time to burn your
clothes in the car open and empty the
safe and then ditch the safe and then
switch to a new car some safes have
trackers so you'll need to keep moving
once you're sure you're not being
followed you can move to the last step
converting your jewelry into cash
[Music]
the easiest way to get rid of stolen
jewelry fast is to go to a fence a fence
is a connect you have that can give you
cash for whatever you steal they'll buy
whatever you're selling for around 30 of
what it's worth so if you still one
million dollars worth of jewelry three
hundred thousand dollars isn't too bad a
fence is the easiest and fastest
solution and therefore the safest
solution however if you're willing to
take a bit more risk you can make a
bigger percentage get the gold melted
down find an underground jeweler to
re-cut those loose diamonds this is
risky though because the cops know where
to look for people recutting gems but if
you pull it off you could walk away with
at least double of what you could get
from a fence whichever option you choose
get rid of the stolen goods as fast as
possible once they're out of your hands
you can start enjoying the sweet rewards
of your hard work
and now that you've completed this
tutorial you should probably learn how
to make legitimate money because there
are kids out there making millions more
than you would jpegs and no risk of
going to prison for half of their life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]